If you think about it, it's a strange thing for a very rich man to do to run for president because it means throwing yourself into a thousand tedious and potentially demeaning situations. For instance, you show up at a debate with the other millionaires who are running for president, and you try to make a joke out of the negative ads they are running against you. "You didn't even use a good picture of me," you protest, "so I brought you some pictures." You wave a few snapshots into the air. You try to turn this debate into something on your own terms. You try to seize the moment.
仔细想想，一个非常有钱的人去竞选总统是一件很奇怪的事情，因为这意味着你要把自己置身于成千上万个繁琐且可能令人难堪的情境中。比如，你和其他同样竞选总统的百万富翁一起参加辩论，并试图拿他们针对你投放的负面广告开个玩笑。“你们用的甚至不是我的好看照片，”你抗议道，“所以我带了一些照片来。”你挥舞着几张快照，试图按自己的方式将这场辩论引入正题。你试图抓住那个时刻。
You pass the photos to one of your millionaire opponents. He does not even look at them. He tells you that no pretty pictures are going to change your lousy record on taxes. You come off terribly. Another bad moment. Well, this actually happened to Bob Dole just last February. Bob Dole, now the presumptive Republican nominee to the presidency.
你把照片递给其中一位百万富翁对手。他甚至看都不看一眼。他告诉你，再漂亮的照片也无法改变你在税收问题上糟糕的记录。你的表现糟糕透顶。又是尴尬的一刻。好吧，这实际上就是鲍勃·多尔（Bob Dole）在去年二月经历的事情。鲍勃·多尔，如今已是共和党推定的总统候选人。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life , your weekly program documenting life in these here United States through whatever radio storytelling means we believe will amuse you and ourselves. I'm Ira Glass, and today we consider the stories of three men who had the option of comfortable, decent lives and decided to do something wildly eccentric instead, like run for president.
各位好，这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），这是一个记录美国生活的每周节目，我们通过任何我们认为能让您和我们感到有趣的广播故事方式来呈现。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），今天我们来看看三个人的故事，他们本可以选择舒适、体面的生活，却决定做出一些极其古怪的事情，比如竞选总统。
Act One concerns a politician you have probably never heard of. Act Two is a man who wrote a very strange letter to his yet unborn, yet unconceived, children. Act Three, another mixed legacy of a rich guy. Stay with us.
第一幕讲述了一位你可能从未听说过的政治家。第二幕是一位给未出生、甚至尚未受孕的孩子写了一封非常奇怪信的男人。第三幕是另一位富豪留下的复杂遗产。请继续收听。
Act One, The Grizz. Over the last few months, a reporter named Michael Lewis has been publishing campaign diaries in The New Republic . I don't know if you've seen these or not. They're pretty great. He's also a columnist for the New York Times , a commentator on Marketplace , author of three books including one called Liar's Poker that is a pretty hilarious account of Wall Street in the '80s.
第一幕，《灰熊》。在过去几个月里，一位名叫迈克尔·刘易斯（Michael Lewis）的记者一直在《新共和》（The New Republic）杂志上发表竞选日记。我不知道你们有没有看过。它们非常棒。他也是《纽约时报》的专栏作家，《Marketplace》节目的评论员，著有三本书，其中包括《说谎者的扑克牌》（Liar's Poker），那是一部关于80年代华尔街的非常滑稽的叙述。
This is a guy whose reporting reads like a novel, usually a pretty entertaining, funny novel. And on the campaign trail, he has noticed a hundred telling moments that no other reporter has documented. Like, for example, the day that Al Franken of Saturday Night Live showed up at a Pat Buchanan rally and picked a fight with some pro-Buchanan military cadets. Like, for example, Pat Buchanan railing against a Detroit steel mill closing but then quietly turning down the offer to actually sit on the board of directors of the mill and try to save it.
这家伙的报道读起来就像小说，通常是那种相当有趣、好笑的小说。在竞选过程中，他注意到了成百上千个其他记者从未记录过的细节时刻。比如，《周六夜现场》的阿尔·弗兰肯（Al Franken）出现在帕特·布坎南（Pat Buchanan）的集会上，并与一些支持布坎南的军校学员挑起争端。再比如，帕特·布坎南激烈抨击底特律一家钢铁厂倒闭，但随后又悄悄拒绝了进入该厂董事会试图拯救它的提议。
And then, at some point, Michael Lewis became fascinated with some of the candidates that everyone else was ignoring. And by everyone else, I include both the reporters and the voters, OK? There were nine Republican candidates back in Iowa. And if you can name all nine of those candidates right now, I've got a crisp $100 bill right here in my hand. Call this station, and no, I'm not going to give you the phone number.
后来，在某个时刻，迈克尔·刘易斯对其他所有人都在忽视的一些候选人产生了浓厚兴趣。我所说的“其他人”，既包括记者也包括选民，明白吗？当时在爱荷华州有九位共和党候选人。如果你现在能把这九位候选人的名字全部报出来，我手头这张崭新的100美元钞票就是你的。拨打本台电话吧——不，我不会告诉你电话号码的。
Please consider now, when you consider these nine candidates, what could be a better subject for an entertaining, novelistic kind of writer than someone running for president who has pretty much no chance of making it? There you have a truly American story. There you have a classic American dreamer. And Lewis became so interested in one of these certain losers-- a guy named Morry Taylor-- that at some point, Lewis' editor got completely fed up with him and ordered him never to follow around Taylor anymore. "I did not send you out there to write Morry Taylor's biography," the guy said.
请现在想想，当你考虑这九位候选人时，还有什么比一个几乎没有胜算的竞选者更好的娱乐性、小说化写作题材呢？那里有一个地道的美国故事。那里有一个经典的美国梦想家。刘易斯对其中一位彻头彻尾的失败者——一个叫莫里·泰勒（Morry Taylor）的家伙——变得如此着迷，以至于到后来，刘易斯的编辑彻底对他失去了耐心，命令他再也不准跟随泰勒。“我没派你去写莫里·泰勒的传记，”那人说。
But it is easy to see why Lewis became so mesmerized with Taylor. Taylor would give away cash prizes to voters at his rallies. Taylor would burst onto stages reciting the words to his campaign theme song, Bruce Springsteen's "Dancing in the Dark." He would say, "You need a spark to start a fire, and this gun's for hire."
但很容易理解为什么刘易斯会被泰勒所吸引。泰勒会在集会上向选民发放现金奖励。泰勒会冲上舞台，背诵他竞选主题曲的歌词，即布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀（Bruce Springsteen）的《在黑暗中跳舞》（Dancing in the Dark）。他会说：“你需要火花才能点燃火焰，而这把枪是用来雇佣的。”
Taylor spent $6 million of his own money on the campaign. As Lewis points out, of nine Republican candidates, Taylor was the only one who had actually been a success in the real business world. Taylor began as a tool and die maker, bought failing companies, made them profitable. And by last year, his own company, Titan Tire and Wheel International-- I'll just say that name again, let's just pause on that name, Titan Tire and Wheel International-- tallied $620 million in revenue, no debt, and one of the highest profit margins of any company on the New York Stock Exchange.
泰勒在竞选中自掏腰包花了600万美元。正如刘易斯指出的那样，在九位共和党候选人中，泰勒是唯一一个真正在商业世界中取得成功的人。泰勒以制造工具和模具起家，收购濒临倒闭的公司并使其盈利。去年，他自己的公司——泰坦轮胎与车轮国际公司（Titan Tire and Wheel International）——我再重申一遍这个名字，让我们停顿一下这个名字——泰坦轮胎与车轮国际公司，其营收达到了6.2亿美元，零负债，且拥有纽约证券交易所中任何公司里最高的利润率之一。
Morry Taylor has spent his whole life in the Midwest, and that is where Michael Lewis' diaries on him begin. Michael Lewis agreed to come into our studios and read.
莫里·泰勒一生都在中西部度过，这也是迈克尔·刘易斯关于他的日记的起点。迈克尔·刘易斯同意来到我们的演播室朗读这些内容。
January 11. Within minutes of landing in Des Moines, you know that you have arrived in the American Midwest. The Midwest is the straight man of the Western world, millions and millions of square miles peopled with Abbotts without their Costellos. It's not that Midwesterners lack a sense of humor. It's just that they regard humor as a second-rate behavior, the opposite of rather than a complement to seriousness. It's no wonder that professional Midwestern humorists like Garrison Keillor and David Letterman have a feel of men who have spun out of some orbit.
1月11日。降落在得梅因后的几分钟内，你就知道你已经抵达了美国中西部。中西部是西方世界的“直男”，数百万平方英里的土地上住满了没有搭档的阿博特（Abbott）。并非中西部人缺乏幽默感。只是他们将幽默视为一种二流行为，是严肃的对立面而非补充。难怪像加里森·凯勒（Garrison Keillor）和大卫·莱特曼（David Letterman）这样的专业中西部幽默大师，总给人一种脱离了某种轨道的感觉。
I've come to Iowa to find Morry Taylor, the man who by a landslide won the hearts of the United We Stand delegates at Ross Perot's convention last fall. After hearing him speak, 400 of the 2,000 people present signed up to work on his campaign. The strange thing about Taylor is that he hasn't gotten more play in the press or the polls. He's the real thing, an extremely successful businessmen who has behaved about as well as an extremely successful businessman can.
我来到爱荷华州寻找莫里·泰勒，那个在去年秋天罗斯·佩罗（Ross Perot）的集会上，以压倒性优势赢得了“我们团结起来”（United We Stand）代表们青睐的男人。在听完他的演讲后，到场的2000人中有400人报名参加了他的竞选团队。泰勒奇怪之处在于，他在媒体或民意调查中并没有获得更多关注。他是真正的实干家，一位表现得像极了成功商人的成功商人。
He employs 5,500 people at a wage rate of $12 to $17 an hour, all of whom are included in a profit sharing plan. He pays himself a modest salary and argues forcefully and often that CEOs of publicly held corporations should never be paid more than about 20 times the wages of their most menial workers. Actually, that's probably one of the reasons no one has heard of him until now.
他雇用了5500名员工，工资水平为每小时12到17美元，所有人都包含在利润分享计划中。他给自己支付适度的薪水，并反复有力地论证，上市公司CEO的薪酬永远不应超过其最底层员工工资的20倍。事实上，这可能就是为什么直到现在都没人听说过他的原因之一。
January 12. We start our day just before 8 o'clock inside a motor home plastered all over with Morry's favorite screaming eagle logo, the one his campaign staffers plead with him to abandon. A ferocious-looking bird flies out of the T in Morry's last name, which is painted in huge letters across the side of the colossal machine.
1月12日。我们的一天在早上8点前就开始了，地点是在一辆房车内，车身上贴满了莫里最喜欢的尖叫鹰标志，就是那个他的竞选工作人员恳求他放弃的标志。一只面目狰狞的鸟从莫里姓氏开头的字母“T”中飞出，该字母被漆在那个庞然大物侧面的巨大位置上。
Morry's campaign manager tried to talk him out of the expense, but Morry insisted that the best way to start running for president was to buy six RVs-- landyachts, they are called-- and race them in a convoy across each of Iowa's 99 counties and through every New Hampshire hamlet. Six monstrosities all jammed together and churning down the highway at 80 miles an hour with the Pointer Sisters blaring out of the lead vehicle, drowning out everything but Morry.
莫里的竞选经理试图说服他放弃这项开支，但莫里坚持认为，竞选总统的最佳方式就是买六辆房车——也就是所谓的“陆地游艇”——然后排成一队横穿爱荷华州的所有99个县，并穿过新罕布什尔州的每一个村庄。六个怪物挤在一起，以每小时80英里的速度在高速公路上疾驰，领头的车里播放着指针姐妹（Pointer Sisters）的音乐，掩盖了除了莫里以外的一切声音。
Morry figured that he'd roll them into town, surround the courthouse, flip on the loudspeakers, tap a few kegs of beer, and everyone for miles would be talking about Morry Taylor for the next two weeks. He was right.
莫里想的是，他会把它们开进镇子，围住法院，打开扬声器，敲开几桶啤酒，然后方圆几英里内的所有人接下来两周都会谈论莫里·泰勒。他猜对了。
Today, like every other day, Morry is wearing his American flag tie. He's shouting over music and the roar of the landyacht into a telephone at a radio talk show. "Anyone who wants to come and help, call 1-800-USABEAR. The talk show host asks him some question. "Well," replies Morry, "I use the bear number because my nickname is The Grizz."
今天，像往常一样，莫里系着他的美国国旗领带。他对着电话里的广播访谈节目，盖过音乐声和陆地游艇的轰鸣声大喊：“任何想来帮忙的人，拨打1-800-USABEAR。”主持人问了他几个问题。“好吧，”莫里回答说，“我使用这个‘熊’（BEAR）号码是因为我的绰号叫‘灰熊’（The Grizz）。”
"Why do they call you The Grizz?" I ask after he hangs up. "I got that when I took the company public," he shouts. "At the closing, they gave me this plaque. It says-- and they did it in Latin, which language I can't speak, but this is what it says-- in North America, there is no known predator to the grizzly. So I became The Grizz. Then I thought about it. Up until that time, I kind of liked my other nickname, Attila. People think Attila the Hun was a barbarian, but he's not. He's the guy who ran the Roman legion out of town.
“为什么他们叫你‘灰熊’？”他挂断电话后我问。“我在公司上市时得到的这个外号，”他大喊道。“在闭幕时，他们给了我这块牌匾。上面写着——他们用的是拉丁文，我不会说那种语言，但大致意思是——在北美，没有已知的灰熊天敌。所以我成了‘灰熊’。后来我想了想，在此之前，我其实挺喜欢我的另一个绰号，‘阿提拉’。人们认为匈奴王阿提拉是个野蛮人，但他不是。他是那个把罗马军团赶出城的人。”
At 9 o'clock, the landyacht rolls up beside the front door of the Ames High School and disgorges Morry. Morry then does his usual trick of startling the locals. He bursts through both double doors leading into the school, which, like all the doors he will open for the rest of the day, slam violently against the wall behind them. He marches off down a long corridor with the rest of us trying to keep up, leaving a trail of startled adolescents in his wake. He swaggers like a quarterback on the way to a huddle.
早上9点，陆地游艇停在艾姆斯高中前门旁，莫里走了下来。接着，莫里使出了他那套让当地人震惊的惯用伎俩。他猛地推开通往学校的两扇双开门，像他这一整天推开的所有门一样，门重重地撞在身后的墙上。他沿着长长的走廊大步走去，我们剩下的人努力跟上，在他身后留下了一串受惊的青少年。他走起路来像个正走向战术讨论区的四分卫。
"Did you play sports in high school?" I ask Morry, or rather, the back of Morry's head. He doesn't even look around. He's shaking his head. I have no trouble imagining the scorn on his face. "Did I play sports?" he asks. "I am the biggest jock who ever ran for president. I can beat you in anything." And with that, he blows through the double doors leading into the auditorium.
“你高中时参加过体育运动吗？”我问莫里，或者说是问莫里的后脑勺。他甚至没有回头。他在摇头。我能想象出他脸上不屑的表情。“我参加过运动吗？”他反问，“我是竞选总统的人里最棒的运动员。任何运动我都能打败你。”说完，他吹着口哨穿过了通往礼堂的双开门。
About 30 kids file in, slump down into their seats, and settle in for a snooze they'll never have. "Your school is too big," booms Morry. "This is what is wrong with America," he says, pointing at the kids. "Big, big, big. A place like this breeds weirdos."
大约30个孩子走进来，瘫坐在座位上，准备迎接他们永远不会有的瞌睡。“你们的学校太大了，”莫里轰隆隆地说。“这就是美国的问题所在，”他说，指着孩子们。“大，大，大。这种地方只会培养怪胎。”
The students are now fully alert. "I never could enjoy going to a school like this," concludes Morry. The kids seem to concur. "How many of you ever take accounting?" he asks. The kids are now squirming and ducking. He's breaking down their resistance, making them nervous. Two hands go up. Morry shakes his head a little sadly.
学生们现在完全清醒了。“我从来没法享受在这样的学校上学，”莫里总结道。孩子们似乎表示赞同。“你们中有多少人学过会计？”他问。孩子们现在开始扭动身体，想要躲避。他正在打破他们的心理防线，让他们感到紧张。两只手举了起来。莫里略带悲伤地摇了摇头。
His tone changes. "I know you've got a lot of these teachers." He waves nonchalantly at a couple of uneasy-looking older men in the rafters. "And they tell you a lot of--" he doesn't use the word "crap" but he might as well-- "things. But in your whole entire life, you're only going to use one or maybe two of those things." He pauses and seems to reconsider. "Now, we all agree that the most important thing in your life is your family," he says. "Your mama and your daddy, your brothers and your sisters. But right after that, there's something else. We all know what it is, and it's green."
他的语气变了。“我知道你们有很多这样的老师。”他漫不经心地向看台上几个看起来不安的老年人挥了挥手。“他们告诉你们很多……”他没用“胡扯”这个词，但意思差不多，“……东西。但在你的一生中，你可能只会用到其中一两样。”他停顿了一下，似乎重新考虑了一下。“现在，我们都同意，你生命中最重要的事情是你的家庭，”他说，“你的妈妈和爸爸，你的兄弟和姐妹。但在那之后，还有别的东西。我们都知道那是什么，它是绿色的。”
With that, he reaches into his pocket and produces a fat roll of $100 bills. He holds it high so that everyone can see. Five grand, cash. The kids are now perched on the edge of their seats, giggling nervously. "It all comes down to accounting," says Morry. "Accounting and money. You can't live without it. And the minute you make it, someone is trying to take it away from you. So for god's sake, find out about money."
说完，他伸手进兜，掏出一叠厚厚的100美元钞票。他高高举起，让每个人都能看到。五千美元，现金。孩子们现在坐在椅子边缘，紧张地咯咯笑着。“一切都归结为会计，”莫里说，“会计和金钱。没有它你就活不下去。而当你赚到钱的那一刻，就有人想从你手里抢走它。所以，看在上帝的份上，去了解金钱吧。”
"Can I have some?" asks a kid in the front row. "It's mine!" shouts Morry and puts the money back in his pocket, a nice illustration of some general business principle.
“我能拿一些吗？”前排的一个孩子问。“这是我的！”莫里喊道，把钱塞回了口袋，这很好地说明了一个通用的商业原则。
Morry's positions are somewhat quixotic. He's running on a platform of balancing the budget in 18 months, not by eliminating programs but by firing a third of the best-paid government employees. "How many of you want to give the government 40% of what you earn after you get out of here?" he asks the crowd. One of the kids raises his hand. "Mark his name down," says Morry. "An institution needs him. We're going to study his brain. He's not human. He's an alien."
莫里的立场有些不切实际。他的竞选纲领是18个月内平衡预算，不是通过取消项目，而是通过解雇三分之一薪水最高的高级政府雇员。“你们中有多少人想在毕业后把收入的40%交给政府？”他问人群。其中一个孩子举起了手。“记下他的名字，”莫里说，“某个机构需要他。我们要研究他的大脑。他不是人类。他是外星人。”
January 13. Tonight, we flew in one of Morry's private planes to a Republican county dinner at Storm Lake in Northwestern Iowa. After dinner, Morry rises to speak. He's on. Within minutes, he has the crowd laughing and clapping. They agree with him about everything, especially the lunacy of the Forbes tax plan. Then, in the midst of the fun, a woman rises and challenges his pro-choice position.
1月13日。今晚，我们乘坐莫里的一架私人飞机前往爱荷华州西北部风暴湖（Storm Lake）的一个共和党县级晚宴。晚宴后，莫里起身发言。他进入状态了。几分钟内，他就让全场观众大笑并鼓掌。他们同意他关于一切的看法，尤其是福布斯（Forbes）税收计划的荒谬性。然后，在欢乐的气氛中，一位女士站起来挑战他支持堕胎的立场。
"It's a religious issue," Morry says, "not a matter for the federal government." She presses him. You can see she's used to making public speakers either come around to her way of thinking or regret ever opening their mouths. She's picked the wrong guy today. Instead of backing down or wiggling, Morry goes on the attack.
“这是一个宗教问题，”莫里说，“不是联邦政府该管的事。”她继续追问。你可以看出她习惯于让公共演讲者要么转而认同她的观点，要么后悔张开嘴。她今天选错了对象。莫里没有退缩或闪躲，而是发起了反击。
"Look, ma'am. I think 99% of women never want an abortion. They go through a lot of mental anguish. They suffer a lot. I say leave it to them." She tries to speak. Morry interrupts. "I said, leave it to the women." And there, at a banquet filled with Republican party hacks, the sort of people who are meant to be rabidly pro-life, who Morry expected to be rabidly pro-life, a volcano of spontaneous applause erupted. All over the room, women were clapping so hard I thought they'd break their hands. Here, I thought, is the benefit of having someone around who feels free to speak his mind. He liberates, however momentarily, those who don't.
“听着，女士。我认为99%的女性从来都不想堕胎。她们经历了太多的心理煎熬。她们遭受了很多痛苦。我说，把这件事留给她们自己决定。”她试图说话。莫里打断了她。“我说过，留给女性自己决定。”就在那里，在一个挤满了共和党党棍的宴会上，那些本该是狂热的反堕胎主义者，那些莫里预料会是狂热反堕胎的人，爆发出一阵自发的掌声。在整个房间里，女人们都在拼命鼓掌，我以为她们的手都要拍断了。我想，这就是让一个敢于说出心里话的人在身边的益处。他解放了那些不敢说话的人，哪怕只是短暂地。
January 14. I was waiting at the front desk of the Des Moines YMCA when Morry arrived just before 9:00 AM. "What, do you think I wouldn't show?" he says. The racquetball game took just under 22 minutes. Morry won, 15-zip, 15-5. I had figured that between the 25 extra pounds he's carrying around and the 16 years he has on me, I could out-hustle him. I was wrong. He knew every angle and trick on the court and played each one with relish. "Too good," he'd shout after he'd drop the ball into the corner for the 10th time.
1月14日。莫里在上午9点前到达时，我正在得梅因基督教青年会（YMCA）的前台等着。“怎么，你以为我不会出现吗？”他说。壁球比赛花了不到22分钟。莫里赢了，15比0，15比5。我本以为凭他身上多出的25磅体重，再加上他比我年长16岁，我可以胜过他。我错了。他熟悉球场上的每一个角度和技巧，并津津有味地运用每一个。第10次将球打入死角后，他大喊：“太棒了。”
As the rout progressed, he shouted to his aides. "14 to zip. Not bad for an old guy," he shouted. And then, under his breath, "Some of my guys are betting on you. Dip [BLEEP]." As we crawl through the hole out the back of the court, he says, "Don't you go write that you lost because you were nervous a presidential candidate was going to have a heart attack." Camus identified the love of winning at games as one of the prerequisites of happiness in the modern world. And he did that without ever meeting Morry.
随着比赛一边倒地进行，他对着助手们大喊。“14比0。对于一个老家伙来说还不错，”他喊道。然后，压低声音说，“我手下有些人正赌你会输。该死的。”当我们从球场后方的小洞爬出来时，他说：“别写你是输了，因为你紧张得以为总统候选人要心脏病发作了。”加缪（Camus）将对游戏获胜的热爱视为现代世界幸福的先决条件之一。而他甚至没见过莫里就得出了这个结论。
More of Michael Lewis' campaign diaries and Morry Taylor later in our show. Stay with us.
稍后节目中会有更多迈克尔·刘易斯的竞选日记和莫里·泰勒的内容。请继续收听。
So Jack, let's start here. This is the case of Hecht v. California , right?
那么杰克（Jack），我们从这里开始。这是赫克特诉加州案（Hecht v. California），对吧？
Right. The facts of the case-- and let me just go straight to the unaffected prose of the judges. This introduces all the characters and the essential events of the case. "At the age of 48, William Kane took his own life on October 30, 1991 in a Las Vegas hotel. For about five years prior to his death, he had been living with a petitioner, 38-year-old Deborah Hecht. Kane was survived by two college-age children of his former wife, whom he had divorced in 1976."
没错。案件的事实——我直接引用法官不带个人感情的陈述吧。这介绍了案件的所有人物和基本事件。“1991年10月30日，48岁的威廉·凯恩（William Kane）在拉斯维加斯的一家酒店自杀身亡。在他去世前的五年左右，他一直与原告、38岁的黛博拉·赫克特（Deborah Hecht）同居。凯恩身后留下了与前妻所生的两个大学生孩子，他于1976年与前妻离婚。”
OK, so now we have a dead guy, his girlfriend, two kids, and a former wife. But that is not all we have of citizen William Kane's life. We also have--
好吧，现在我们有了死者、他的女朋友、两个孩子和一个前妻。但这并不是公民威廉·凯恩生命中的全部。我们还有——
15 vials of his sperm in an account at California Cryobank, Inc.
在加州冷冻库公司（California Cryobank, Inc.）的一个账户里，有15小瓶他的精子。
And this is where the story of this willful man with money begins. It is our contributing editor Jack Hitt who reviewed the case for us. Jack's work regularly appears not just on this program but in the New York Times Magazine , Harper's , Esquire , Lingua Franca , and too many other publications to name.
这就是这个意志坚定的有钱人的故事开始的地方。这是我们的特约编辑杰克·希特（Jack Hitt），他为我们回顾了这个案子。杰克不仅经常出现在本节目中，他的文章也常见于《纽约时报杂志》、《哈珀》、《时尚先生》、《通用语言》以及其他数不清的刊物上。
But let us get back to citizen William Kane. Mr. Kane does not have Morry Taylor's kind of money, but he did have enough. And in his will, he declared that if his girlfriend would use any of the--
但让我们回到公民威廉·凯恩身上。凯恩先生没有莫里·泰勒那样的财力，但他确实有一些钱。在遗嘱中，他声明如果他的女朋友会使用这些——
15 vials of sperm.
15小瓶精子。
--and succeeded in getting pregnant, then the resulting child would get some of Kane's personal mementos and possibly the rights to some money. This is an odd case of American jurisprudence, and the legal opinion includes the letter that William Kane wrote to his unborn, yet to be conceived child, Wyatt. Jack Hitt reads.
——并成功怀孕，那么出生的孩子将获得凯恩的一些个人纪念品，并可能获得某些资金的权利。这是美国法理学中一个奇怪的案例，法律意见书中包含了威廉·凯恩写给他未出生、甚至尚未受孕的孩子怀亚特（Wyatt）的信。杰克·希特朗读：
"I address this to my children because although I have only two, Everett and Katie, it may be that Deborah will decide, as I hope she will, to have a child by me after my death. I've been assiduously generating frozen sperm samples for that eventuality. If she does, then this letter is for my posthumous offspring as well, with the thought that I have loved you in my dreams, even though I never got to see you born. If you are receiving this letter, it means that I am dead. Whether by my own hand or that of another makes very little difference.
“我写给我的孩子们，因为虽然我只有两个孩子，埃弗雷特（Everett）和凯蒂（Katie），但黛博拉可能会决定，正如我所希望的那样，在我死后生下我的孩子。我一直在勤奋地保存冷冻精子样本以应对那种可能性。如果她真的这么做了，那么这封信也是写给我死后的后代的，想到我曾在梦中爱过你们，尽管我没能见到你们出生。如果你收到这封信，意味着我已经死了。无论是因为我自己的手还是他人的手，都没有太大区别。”
I feel that my time has come, and I wanted to leave you with something more than a dead enigma that was your father. I am inordinately proud of who I've been, what I made of me. I'm so proud of that that I would rather take my own life now than be ground into a mediocre existence by my enemies who, because of my mistakes and bravado, have gained the power to finish me."
“我觉得我的时候到了，我不想给你们留下一个死去的谜团作为父亲。我对自己是谁，我创造了什么感到无比自豪。我对此感到非常自豪，以至于我宁愿现在就结束自己的生命，也不愿被我的敌人们蹂躏成平庸的存在，因为我的错误和虚张声势，他们获得了摧毁我的权力。”
How many people do we know in our lives, Jack, who can say a sentence like that?
在我们生活中认识的人里，杰克，有多少人能说出这样的话？
Every sentence in this letter is worthy of study. I mean, from "I've been assiduously generating frozen sperm samples for that eventuality," to "If you are receiving this letter, it means that I am dead." And it goes on, Ira. Check this out.
这封信里的每一句话都值得研究。我是说，从“我一直在勤奋地保存冷冻精子样本以应对那种可能性”，到“如果你收到这封信，意味着我已经死了”。还有更多内容，艾拉。看看这个。
So he has several pages about his childhood memories and the family history. And then, quote, "So why am I checking out now? Basically, betrayal, over and over again, has made me tired. I've picked up some heavyweight enemies along the way, ranging from the Kellys of the world to crazies with guns to insurance agencies to the lawyers that have sucked me dry. I don't want to die as a tired, perhaps defeated and bitter old man. I'd rather end it like I have lived it. On my time, when and where I will."
所以他写了好几页关于他的童年记忆和家庭历史的内容。然后，引语，“那么我为什么现在要离开呢？基本上，一次又一次的背叛让我感到疲惫。我在路上结下了一些重量级的敌人，从世上的凯利一家到持枪的疯子，到保险机构，再到榨干我的律师们。我不想作为一个疲惫、或许被击败且痛苦的老人死去。我宁愿像我活着那样结束生命。在我自己的时间，我想在哪里就在哪里，想什么时候就在什么时候。”
[SINGING] Regrets, I have a few. But then again--
[歌唱] 遗憾，我有一些。但话说回来——
But Ira, listen to this next sentence.
但是艾拉，听听下一句。
--too few to mention. I've lived a life that's full--
——寥寥无几。我过着充实的生活——
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
But we digress.
但我们跑题了。
He says, "I'd rather end it like I have lived it. On my time, when and where I will, and while my life is still an object of self-sculpture, a personal creation with which I am still proud. In truth, death for me is not the opposite of life. It is a form of life's punctuation." End quote.
他说：“我宁愿像我活着那样结束生命。在我自己的时间，我想在哪里就在哪里，想什么时候就在什么时候，而我的生活仍然是一个自我雕塑的对象，一个我依然引以为傲的个人作品。事实上，死亡对我来说不是生命的对立面。它是生命的一种标点符号。”引用结束。
I like him. It's like a Martin Scorsese film.
我喜欢他。这就像一部马丁·斯科塞斯（Martin Scorsese）的电影。
Yeah. And he's got this tough-guy thing. Here he is talking to his kid. I love that phrase, "So why am I checking out now?" Oh, by the way, just to make it even more interesting and soap opera-ish, the lawyer for the two kids, her name is Sandra Erwin. If you read carefully elsewhere, you find out that she is their mother. and Mr. Kane's original wife.
是的。他有种“硬汉”做派。这里他正在和他的孩子说话。我喜欢那句，“那么我为什么现在要离开呢？”噢，顺便说一下，为了让它更有趣、更有肥皂剧色彩，那两个孩子的律师，她的名字叫桑德拉·欧文（Sandra Erwin）。如果你仔细查阅其他资料，你会发现她是他们的母亲，也是凯恩先生的前妻。
Wow.
哇。
So the lawyer suing the girlfriend is, in fact, the first recipient of Mr. Kane's sperm. And then, in a footnote, you sort of discover just what the relationship is between the Kane children-- the existing children, as I call them-- and Deborah. So this is just a footnote just dropped in the text. And this pretty much says everything you need to know.
所以起诉女朋友的律师，实际上是凯恩先生精子的第一位接收者。然后，在脚注里，你会发现现有的凯恩孩子们——我称他们为现有孩子——和黛博拉之间的关系。这只是随意丢在文中的脚注。它几乎说明了你需要知道的一切。
"On November 12, 1992, decedents children filed against Hecht a complaint for wrongful death and intentional infliction of emotional distress wherein they allege that their father, who had been unemployed for some time, became deeply depressed and began to seriously contemplate suicide about September 1, 1991. For six weeks before his death, Hecht was aware of decedent's quote, 'disturbed plan' end quote, to end his life, that Hecht convinced him to allow her to have his child after his death and leave her a substantial amount of his property to raise and care for this child. In the week before his death, Hecht encouraged and assisted decedent in transferring property to her."
“1992年11月12日，死者的孩子针对赫克特提起了不当死亡和故意造成精神痛苦的诉讼，他们声称，死者在失业一段时间后，变得极其沮丧，并于1991年9月1日左右开始认真考虑自杀。在去世前的六周内，赫克特知晓了死者结束生命的‘不安计划’，赫克特说服死者允许她在死后生下他的孩子，并留下他的一大部分财产来抚养和照料这个孩子。在去世前的一周，赫克特鼓励并协助死者将财产转移给她。”
And she also generously helped him, quote, "empty his personal checking account by issuing a check to Hecht for $80,000," which you learn elsewhere she signed herself. And then here's my favorite sentence. "Hecht assisted decedent in purchasing a one-way ticket to Las Vegas and took him to the airport."
她还慷慨地帮助他，“通过开出一张给赫克特的8万美元支票来清空他的个人支票账户”，你在其他地方会了解到那是她自己签名的。然后这是我最喜欢的一句。“赫克特协助死者购买了一张去拉斯维加斯的单程机票，并送他去了机场。”
I wonder what that curbside conversation was like.
我想知道那场在路边的谈话是什么样的。
Can you imagine? She bought a one-way ticket to Las Vegas, knowing that he was going to go sit in a hotel, take pills. She also, by the way, bought him the plastic bag that he put over his head after he took the pills. She gave him a copy of Final Exit , which is a suicide manual.
你能想象吗？她买了一张去拉斯维加斯的单程票，明知他要去酒店坐着吃药自杀。顺便说一下，她还帮他买了那个他在吃完药后套在头上的塑料袋。她给了他一份《最终出口》（Final Exit）的副本，那是一本自杀手册。
The plastic bag to put over his head after he takes the pills? Isn't that the whole point of pills is that you don't have to do the ugly thing of getting a gun or plastic bags? I mean, isn't that the whole point?
吃完药后套在头上的塑料袋？吃药的目的不就是为了不用去用枪或塑料袋做那些丑陋的事情吗？我是说，这不就是重点吗？
Ira, you're not up on your suicide manuals. According to Derek Humphry-- I believe that's the man's name who wrote Final Exit-- quite often, if you take a lot of pills, a lot of people will just end up getting sick, and you will live. So the idea is, yes, you take the pills to make sure that you will die, and then you suffocate yourself--
艾拉，你不了解自杀手册。据德里克·汉弗莱（Derek Humphry）所说——我相信这就是写《最终出口》那个人的名字——很多时候，如果你吃了很多药，很多人最终只会感到恶心，然后你还会活着。所以思路是，是的，你吃药确保你会死，然后你用袋子闷死自己——
With the plastic bag.
用塑料袋。
--in the bag so that you don't wake up and vomit. It's pretty grim and certainly not the province of this discussion.
——在袋子里，这样你就不会醒来呕吐。这很阴森，肯定不在我们要讨论的范围内。
All right. Well, I'm learning just so much here.
好吧。我确实在这儿学到了很多。
Yes, right. So the thing is, they're not really concerned about the money, because they cut a deal with Debbie. The deal was, we get 80%, you get 20. What they're worried about is that if she gets pregnant-- and this is where this whole case opens up a bizarre form of new law-- what they're worried about is that the child would have a claim to the estate, to their 80%. And, in fact, the child probably would.
是的，没错。所以问题是，他们并不太关心钱，因为他们和黛比达成了协议。协议是，我们拿80%，你拿20%。他们担心的是如果她怀孕了——这是整个案件开启一种奇怪新法的开端——他们担心的是孩子会对遗产有要求，要求分走他们的那80%。实际上，孩子很可能真的会有权要求。
And that's because under his will, he says that if she gets pregnant and has the child, then the child gets some dough?
这是因为在他的遗嘱里，他说了如果她怀孕并生下了孩子，那么孩子就能得到一笔钱？
Well, it's just that it's an unresolved matter. So it's likely that the child would be able to sue later on for the kind of benefits that any natural biological child would be able to sue for. Mr. Kane is the biological father. He just participated in this new science which is referred to in the case with the phrase "post-mortem insemination."
嗯，这只是一个悬而未决的问题。所以很有可能孩子以后能起诉要求任何亲生子女有权要求的福利。凯恩先生是亲生父亲。他只是参与了这项被称为“死后授精”的新科学。
We return to our own post-mortem examination when our program continues.
节目继续，我们回到我们自己的“死后检查”。
Act Two continues our discussion with journalist Jack Hitt about a dead man and his sperm.
第二幕继续我们与记者杰克·希特关于一个死人和他精子的讨论。
So here's what the lawsuit's about. The lawsuit is the existing kids want to destroy the sperm, all of it. 15 vials "assiduously" deposited, as we know. In the course of their complaint, the existing kids say that they seek to, quote, "prevent the disruption of existing families by after-born children."
这就是诉讼的原因。诉讼在于现有的孩子想要摧毁这些精子，全部的精子。我们知道，那是“勤奋”存放的15小瓶。在他们的申诉过程中，这些现有子女声称他们寻求，引用，“防止因后出生的孩子而破坏现有家庭”。
"After-born children." There's another new-- this case, in terms of what it's doing to the English language, is just groundbreaking. Forget about what it does to the law. "After-born children."
“后出生的孩子”。又有一个新的——这个案件在英语用法方面简直是开创性的。别管它对法律造成了什么影响。“后出生的孩子”。
Now, all of this is complicated by the fact that Debbie is 38 years old in 1991. And she makes the claim that she must have the sperm at once because of advanced maternal age.
现在，这一切又因为黛比在1991年已经38岁而变得复杂。她主张由于高龄产妇的因素，她必须立即获得这些精子。
Right. In other words, if she gets a little bit older, she's not going to be able to have any babies.
没错。换句话说，如果她再年长一点，她就没法生孩子了。
So now, the court realizes that they've got a big issue at hand here. What is sperm? Is it property? Is it something bigger? I mean, it exists, at least symbolically, on this kind of Darwinian level about preservation of species and perpetuation of one's own genetic line. And they're very nervous about just saying, let's just destroy this sperm. They don't really want to do that. That's clear.
所以现在，法院意识到他们面前有一个大问题。精子是什么？它是财产吗？它是某种更大的东西吗？我是说，它至少在象征意义上存在于这种关于物种保存和自身基因延续的达尔文层面上。他们非常害怕仅仅说“让我们销毁这些精子”。他们并不真的想那样做。这很清楚。
Wait, let me just be sure I understand this. Because if they say that sperm is property, his wife and children probably can lay some sort of claim to it or say that this is property, and we have some sort of final word over this property. But if it is somehow part of his personhood, then it transcends the category of property.
等等，让我确定我理解这一点。因为如果他们说精子是财产，他的妻子和孩子们可能可以提出某种要求，或者说这是财产，我们对这笔财产有最终决定权。但如果它是他自身人格的一部分，那么它就超越了财产的范畴。
Right. And so they go back to the precedent. And they find some law regarding human tissue. But most of the law regarding that says that once tissue has left your body, then it can be destroyed. It's not yours anymore because who cares, right?
没错。于是他们回溯到先例。他们找到了一些关于人体组织的法律。但大多数相关法律规定，一旦组织离开了你的身体，它就可以被销毁。它不再是你的了，因为谁在乎呢，对吧？
But they point out that you can't just say that about this particular tissue because Mr. Kane, as we know, "assidulously deposited" these particular tissues outside of his body with the intention that it be used for procreation. It's not just, like, sperm sitting around. It's sperm sitting around with great intent. You understand what I'm saying? Intent to become a child.
但他们指出，你不能对这些特定的组织这么说，因为如我们所知，凯恩先生“勤奋地”将这些特定组织存放在体外，目的是为了繁衍。它不仅仅是随便放在那里的精子。它是带着巨大意图存放在那里的精子。你明白我的意思吗？成为孩子的意图。
I charge you of sperm with intent.
我指控你持有具有意图的精子。
Yes, right. Possession of sperm with the intent to inseminate. OK, so elsewhere in this case, the two existing kids plead with the court that it's just weird to have a kid after you're dead.
是的，没错。非法持有以受精为意图的精子。好的，在这个案件的其他地方，那两个现有的孩子向法院哀求，说死后还要生孩子真是太奇怪了。
Is that the word they use, or is that just kind of what it comes down to?
那是他们使用的词吗，还是说这仅仅是事情的本质所在？
Well, no. They just say it's just wrong. They don't know what else to say.
不，他们只是说这不对。他们不知道还能说什么。
They just say, we all can just look at each other in the eye and we know what we mean we say this is just too weird. That's what it comes down to.
他们只是说，我们大家看着对方的眼睛，就知道当我们说这太离谱时是什么意思。这就是问题的所在。
Exactly. Yeah. And in a funny way, on that level, I completely understand them. So the court reflects on this issue historically and points out something that you probably did not know, which is that, quote, "According to the Napoleonic Code from the early 19th century, any child born more than 300 days after the putative father's death is deemed illegitimate," end quote. And what that means is that the guy goes off to war, he gets killed.
没错。而且很有趣的是，在那个层面上，我完全理解他们。所以法院从历史上反思了这个问题，并指出了一点你可能不知道的事，即引用：“根据19世纪早期的《拿破仑法典》，任何在推定父亲去世300天后出生的孩子都被视为非婚生子女”，引文结束。这意味着那个家伙去打仗，然后阵亡了。
Well, the clock starts ticking the last day he was in town. And 300 days after that-- in other words, nine months of pregnancy-- any child born after that can't claim the father's goods. In other words, nine months after the guy's dead, his estate is closed and shut, right? But this is where this case gets very troubling because it keeps it open for potentially ever. As long as the sperm is sitting in the bank with great intent, the estate can't be closed.
时钟从他待在城里的最后一天开始倒计时。在那之后300天——换句话说，怀孕九个月后——任何在那之后出生的孩子都不能要求继承父亲的财产。换句话说，在他死后九个月，他的遗产就彻底结清了，对吧？但这就是此案非常令人困扰的地方，因为它让遗产处于一种可能永远无法关闭的状态。只要精子带着强烈的意图存放在银行里，遗产就无法结清。
So in other words, what seems like a very simple, though odd, family dispute actually raises quite a broad and profound question of the law.
所以换句话说，这个看起来非常简单但又古怪的家庭纠纷，实际上提出了一个相当广泛且深奥的法律问题。
Absolutely. In fact-- and I'll get to this in just a second because there's another thing here that might make your heart stop when I tell you what it is-- this thing, at first when I first read it, I thought OK, this is just a funny little case. No, no, no. This is overthrowing millennia of settled common law, in a funny way. Now, the existing kids, they make all these claims. But there's some that you just have to hear just to think about.
绝对是这样。事实上——我马上就会讲到这一点，因为这里还有另一件事，当我告诉你它是什么时，可能会让你心跳停止——这件事，当我第一次读到它时，我以为这只是一个有趣的小案子。不，不，不。这在某种程度上颠覆了千百年来已经确立的普通法。现在，现有的孩子们提出了各种主张。但有些主张你必须听听，以便思考一下。
One is, quote, "The child could suffer psychologically from being conceived by a dead man." Now, I never really thought about that. But imagine if you grew up, and you knew that your father died five years before you were conceived. It's not like being adopted or where your parentage is somewhat mysterious. That's kind of glamorous in its own way. And at least it's a story you can tell yourself. You can fantasize about who your parents might have been.
一个是，引用：“孩子可能会因为是被死去的男人受孕而遭受心理创伤。”嗯，我以前从未真正想过这个问题。但想象一下，如果你长大了，知道你的父亲在你受孕前五年就去世了。这不像被领养，也不像身世有些神秘。那本身还有点迷人。至少那是一个你可以告诉自己的故事。你可以幻想你的父母可能是谁。
No, no. Well, I mean--
不，不。我是说——
No, but I'm just saying that that has--
不，我只是说这有——
--I believe that this-- Mr. Hitt?
——我相信这——希特先生？
Yeah?
嗯？
The courtroom of this radio studio rejects that argument on these grounds. Because your mom would tell you from the time that you are old enough to understand that your dad wanted to have a child with her and just for some reason was very, very busy and just couldn't get around to it in life. Which, I have to say, is one of the stranger parts of the case, that if he was so intent on having a baby with Ms. Hecht, why didn't he just--
这个广播演播室的法庭驳回了这一论点，理由是：因为你的妈妈会从你懂事起就告诉你，你的爸爸一直想和她生个孩子，只是因为某种原因太忙了，在世时没能抽出时间。我必须说，这是案件中最奇怪的部分之一，如果他那么执意要和赫克特女士生个孩子，为什么他没有直接——
Have a baby with Miss Hecht?
和赫克特小姐生个孩子？
Do we know that?
我们知道那件事吗？
No, that's not even discussed.
不，那甚至没有被讨论过。
OK, let me just go back to our bigger-- the point that--
好的，让我回到我们更大的——那一点，即——
No, wait. You don't think that being conceived by a dead man-- I don't care what the mother's explanation is. I'm sort of on the existing kids' side on this particular part of the argument. It's just strange.
不，等等。你不认为被一个死去的男人受孕——我不在乎母亲的解释是什么。在这个具体的争论点上，我站在现有的孩子那一边。这太奇怪了。
Well, no, because I could imagine very easily the mother saying to the kid--
好吧，不，因为我可以很容易地想象母亲对孩子说——
I don't know, Ira. I think the court of this correspondent just wants it stated for the record that it's weird, it's freaky. This guy, he "checked out" by his own description. He "checked out" because of all "the Kellys of the world" and all that. He couldn't even hang five years to see this kid into kindergarten, OK? I mean, I don't know. To me, something about being dead before you were conceived is very weird.
我不知道，艾拉。我认为这位通讯员的法庭只是想记录在案：这很怪异，很离谱。这家伙，用他自己的话说是“退出了”。他因为“世界上所有的凯利们”等等原因而“退出了”。他甚至没法坚持五年好看着这个孩子上幼儿园，好吗？我的意思是，我不知道。对我来说，在出生前父亲就已经去世，这感觉非常怪异。
OK, here's what's beautiful. What's the resolution eventually? This court dilly dallies and hands it off to another court. But that court finally says, you know what? It's property. Frozen sperm is a special class of property. And so we divide it up according to the rules of the will. 20% goes to Deborah, 80% goes to the two existing kids. So Deborah got three of the 15 vials of sperm. And presumably, the existing children, not that they had anything to do with it, received 12 vials.
好吧，这是最精彩的地方。最终的解决方案是什么？这个法院拖拖拉拉，把它交给了另一个法院。但那个法院最终说，你知道吗？这是财产。冷冻精子是一种特殊类别的财产。因此，我们按照遗嘱的规则进行分配。20%给黛博拉，80%给两个现有的孩子。所以黛博拉得到了15小瓶精子中的3瓶。据推测，现有的孩子，尽管他们与此无关，还是收到了12瓶。
Then Deborah apparently, at age 42, last year, went into a clinic and proceeded to engage in the first instance in American law of post-mortem insemination. That was last fall, I believe. Now, I just want to say one quick thing here.
然后黛博拉显然在去年42岁时，去了一家诊所，进行了美国法律史上首例死后授精。我相信那是去年秋天。现在，我只想在这里说一件事。
I can't wait.
我迫不及待了。
I just want you to consider, Ira, what this could lead to. As I said earlier, death was always the key indicator that an estate could be closed out. But now this loophole, frozen sperm, opens a door that could just keep these post-mortem lawsuits going for decades. It reminds me my friend, Peg Perry. She lives in Northern Connecticut and raises milk cows. And one time, I was up there visiting, and she was inseminating some of the cows. And it turns out the bull semen that she uses is from this bull. He had a name like Ferdinand.
艾拉，我只是想让你考虑一下，这可能会导致什么。正如我之前所说，死亡一直是结清遗产的关键指标。但现在这个漏洞，即冷冻精子，打开了一扇门，可能会让这些死后诉讼持续数十年。这让我想起了我的朋友佩格·佩里。她住在康涅狄格州北部，养奶牛。有一次，我去那里拜访时，她正在给一些奶牛授精。结果她用的公牛精液来自一头公牛。它的名字叫斐迪南。
Oh, it was like Ferdinand.
哦，就像斐迪南。
It's the only bull name I know, Ira.
艾拉，这是我唯一知道的公牛名字。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was going to say, I'm sure you were paying careful attention to that detail.
我本想说，我相信你一定仔细注意到了那个细节。
But this bull-- can I get to the point, Ira? This bull died, like, 40 years ago.
但这头公牛——我能说到重点吗，艾拉？这头公牛大约40年前就死了。
He died in the '50s?
他死于50年代？
He did in 1956 or something. And he had spent his entire life, essentially, assiduously depositing sperm at the local bull bank. And apparently it's really, really good sperm. You really get good milk cows from this particular bull, OK? This bull has several thousand offspring, probably tens of thousands of offspring all over the country producing milk.
他在1956年左右去世的。他一生基本上都在勤勉地在当地的公牛银行存放精子。显然，那是真的非常、非常好的精子。你确实可以从这头特定的公牛那里得到优质的奶牛，好吗？这头公牛有几千个后代，可能全国有成千上万的后代在产奶。
So as of this lawsuit, as of this case, as of this court's ruling, for example, a rich man in California could now leave an estate of, say, $1 billion and many vials of sperm, "assiduously deposited," with the instructions that any fair maiden who wished to carry one of his children to term would receive, let's just say, $500,000, a one-time gift. And given his estate, he could conceivably sire, what is that, 2,000 children over the next century, all now potentially legal in California.
所以根据这个诉讼，根据这个案件，根据这个法院的裁决，例如，加利福尼亚州的一位富人现在可以留下一笔价值，比如10亿美元的遗产和许多“勤勉存放”的精子小瓶，并指示任何愿意怀上他孩子的公正少女都能获得，我们就说50万美元的单次馈赠。考虑到他的遗产，他完全可能在下一个世纪里繁衍，那是多少，2000个孩子，现在在加利福尼亚州都可能合法了。
See, now, if this catches on, these guys are going to stop running for president.
看，如果这流行起来，这些人就会停止竞选总统了。
Exactly. I was just going to say, Perot and Forbes could do something better with their time. They could assiduously-- well, anyway, let's go on.
没错。我正要说，佩罗和福布斯本可以把时间花在更有意义的事情上。他们可以勤勉地——好吧，无论如何，我们继续。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, let's just move on right past that joke.
是的，让我们略过那个笑话继续前进。
Well, we'll just bring this to a close. I found a Legal Weekly in the library yesterday. And I did find that Wyatt Kane may find one other venue of existence after all. Apparently, Deborah Kane has been offered a handsome sum of money by Hollywood producers for the movie rights to this story.
好吧，我们把这件事收个尾。我昨天在图书馆看到了一份《法律周刊》。我确实发现怀亚特·凯恩毕竟可能找到了另一种存在方式。显然，好莱坞制片人向黛博拉·凯恩提供了一笔可观的钱，买下了这个故事的电影版权。
Well, that is the logical place for it. And I say--
嗯，那是它合乎逻辑的归宿。我说——
Well, what is the proper medium for this story? I guess it is the TV movie of the week, really.
好吧，这个故事最合适的媒介是什么？我想它真的是每周电视电影。
No, Jack.
不，杰克。
You think it's bigger than that?
你认为它比那更宏大吗？
Jack, the proper medium for this story, as for any story, Jack Hitt, is radio. And we've just done it. And thank you very much for joining us on our program.
杰克，这个故事——就像杰克·希特的任何故事一样——最合适的媒介是广播。而我们刚刚完成了它。非常感谢你参加我们的节目。
Thank you, Ira.
谢谢你，艾拉。
[MUSIC - "BEATUS VIR"]
[音乐 - "BEATUS VIR"]
Well, this is "Beatus Vir." And when one of our producers, Nancy Updike, got the notes that came with the song, she was really excited because she looked it up. It apparently said that it was Psalm 3-- that was her interpretation. And she looked Psalm 3 in the Bible, and she was astonished at how perfectly ironic the words of Psalm 3 were when put against the story of Citizen Kane.
好吧，这是《Beatus Vir》。当我们的制片人之一南希·厄普代克拿到这首歌的注释时，她非常兴奋，因为她查了一下。注释上显然说这是《诗篇》第3篇——那是她的解读。她查了圣经中的《诗篇》第3篇，并对这首歌词与凯恩公民的故事相对照时是多么完美地讽刺感到震惊。
The words of Psalm 3, "Lord, how they are increased that trouble me. Many are they that rise up against me. I will not be afraid of ten thousands of people that have set themselves against me round about. Arise, O Lord. Save me, O my God. For Thou hast smitten all mine enemies upon the cheekbone. Thou hast broken the teeth of the ungodly." And the Kellys of the world. It doesn't really say that part.
《诗篇》第3篇的歌词是：“耶和华啊，我的敌人何其多，有许多人起来攻击我。我不要惧怕那四围向我攻击的十万人民。耶和华啊，求你起来。我的神啊，求你救我。因为你击打了我一切仇敌的脸颊。你敲碎了恶人的牙齿。”还有世界上的那些凯利们。它并没有真的写那一部分。
Unfortunately, closer inspection of the notes that came with the song reveal that it is not Psalm 3, the words to this song. It's actually Psalm 111, whose words cannot possibly be read in any sort of ironic way against the story of Mr. Kane and his family. But by then, we had fallen so in love with this song, we just had to play it here.
遗憾的是，仔细检查随歌曲附带的注释后发现，这首歌的歌词并不是《诗篇》第3篇。实际上是《诗篇》第111篇，它的歌词绝不可能以任何讽刺的方式来解读凯恩先生和他家庭的故事。但到那时，我们已经爱上了这首歌，我们必须在这里播放它。
February 8. A losing political campaign must at some point cease to be about winning and start to be about something else. A moral crusade, a chance to be on TV, a fundraiser for the next election. In Morry Taylor's case, that something else is fun.
2月8日。一场失败的政治竞选在某个时刻必须不再是为了获胜，而开始转向其他目的。一场道德十字军运动，一个上电视的机会，一场为下届选举的筹款活动。在莫里·泰勒的案例中，那个其他目的就是乐趣。
We now resume Michael Lewis' campaign diaries about failed Republican presidential candidate Morry Taylor. We entitle this act of our program A Candidate, a Voter, and a Room Full of Pigs. To attract attention during the Iowa caucuses, Morry Taylor held five rallies where he gave away a total of $25,000 in a lottery, $5,000 at each of these five rallies. And one of the winners of the $5,000 was a pig farmer named Wilfred McCreedy who just happened to be the host of the Iowa caucus for Republicans in the little town where he lived. These diary entries are from February when the Republican field was still full of people like Lamar Alexander, Phil Gramm, and Alan Keyes.
我们现在继续播出迈克尔·刘易斯关于共和党总统候选人莫里·泰勒竞选失败的日记。我们把这一期节目命名为《一位候选人、一位选民和一屋子猪》。为了在爱荷华州党团会议期间吸引注意力，莫里·泰勒举行了五场集会，共发放了25000美元的抽奖奖金，每场集会发放5000美元。其中一名获得5000美元奖金的获奖者是一位名叫威尔弗雷德·麦克里迪的养猪户，他正好是他所居住小镇共和党爱荷华州党团会议的东道主。这些日记摘录来自二月份，当时共和党阵营仍然充满了像拉马尔·亚历山大、菲尔·格拉姆和艾伦·凯斯这样的人。
February 8. At last, we arrive at the airport. Waiting there are several vans and cars plastered with stickers for Lamar Alexander. Lamar is going places, but as he rises, he is coming under attack, not only from Morry but from Steve Forbes, who has a new commercial explaining how Lamar turned $1,000 into $620,000 with the help of a few friends.
2月8日。我们终于到达了机场。那里停着几辆贴满了拉马尔·亚历山大贴纸的面包车和汽车。拉马尔前途无量，但随着他的崛起，他不仅受到了莫里的攻击，还受到了史蒂夫·福布斯的攻击，福布斯有一则新广告解释了拉马尔是如何在几个朋友的帮助下将1000美元变成了62万美元的。
We enter the terminal. Lamar's jet is circling overhead. He is preparing to land. Lamar does everything with exclamation points. At length, Alexander emerges and is surrounded by the cameras. You can see he is looking for some way to take advantage of the new camera crews. Spotting Morry, now lingering disinterestedly on the tarmac's fringe, Lamar strides over to shake hands.
我们进入航站楼。拉马尔的喷气式飞机正在头顶盘旋。他正准备降落。拉马尔做任何事都带有感叹号。终于，亚历山大露面并被摄像机包围了。你可以看到他正在寻找机会利用这些新的摄像组。发现莫里正漫不经心地停留在停机坪边缘，拉马尔大步走过来握手。
He offers Morry a phony smile and a line from his stump speech. "Just bought my mud boots for all that negative advertising up in New Hampshire." Morry stares at him for a few seconds like he's some kind of nutcase. "That's not negative advertising," he says. "They're just telling you the truth."
他给了莫里一个虚假的微笑，并念了一句他竞选演讲中的台词：“刚为新罕布什尔州的所有那些负面广告买了我的泥靴。”莫里盯着他看了几秒钟，好像他是个疯子。“那不是负面广告，”他说，“他们只是在告诉你真相。”
Lamar's happy face vanishes. Poof. A truly nightmarish sound bite has just occurred. The CBS cameras are rolling. The familiar fight-or-flight instinct takes over. So what does Lamar do? He simply ends the conversation, turns, and racewalks into his car. "Got to go," he hollers over his shoulder as he disappears into the back of his car.
拉马尔的快乐表情消失了。砰。一个真正可怕的采访片段刚刚发生了。CBS的摄像机正在拍摄。熟悉的“战或逃”本能占据了上风。那么拉马尔做了什么？他只是结束了谈话，转身竞走回他的车里。“得走了，”他在消失在车后座时喊道。
"That's what happens when you meet The Grizz," Morry booms after him.
“这就是当你遇到‘灰熊’时会发生的事，”莫里在他身后大声说道。
But the night is still young. Thrilled by a rare, authentic moment, the CBS crew newly assigned to Lamar phones New York. New York orders the crew leave Alexander and to follow Morry wherever he goes next. Morry takes the crew on a tour of Alexander's jet, which looms massively beside Morry's own small plane. "Tell me what is wrong with this picture," I hear him say. "Here you've got a little plane made right here in America, belonging to a guy who has just made his own money. And over here, you've got a $25 million Falconer made in Canada being used by a politician."
但夜晚还很年轻。被一个罕见的、真实的时刻所震撼，被新指派给拉马尔的CBS摄制组给纽约打了电话。纽约命令摄制组离开亚历山大，去跟随莫里接下来去的所有地方。莫里带着摄制组参观了亚历山大的喷气式飞机，它在莫里自己的小型飞机旁边显得巨大无比。“告诉我这张照片有什么不对，”我听见他说，“这里你有一架在美国制造的小飞机，属于一个刚赚到自己钱的人。而在那边，你有一架在加拿大制造的价值2500万美元的猎鹰飞机，正被一个政客使用。”
Four or five carloads of Alexandrians gaze on, helplessly. Meanwhile, overhead, Bob Dole's jet is now circling. Unwisely, it decides to land. There on the tarmac, in the middle of the night, in the middle of nowhere, one third of the Republican field has now assembled. Even more astonishing, the one national news network on hand is trailing around behind the surest loser. Dole's plane rolls inexorably towards Morry and CBS, oblivious to the danger.
四五车亚历山大的支持者无助地看着。与此同时，头顶上，鲍勃·多尔的喷气式飞机正在盘旋。它不明智地决定降落。在停机坪上，在深夜，在荒无人烟的地方，三分之一的共和党候选人现在已经聚集在一起。更令人惊奇的是，在场的唯一一家全国新闻电视网正跟在那个最确定的输家后面。多尔的飞机无情地向莫里和CBS驶去，完全没意识到危险。
"And here," says Morry, "we have another politician. Has he ever made any real money? No. So what's he flying in? A $19 million Challenger. This one is made in France."
“在这里，”莫里说，“我们还有另一个政客。他赚过什么真正的钱吗？没有。那么他坐的是什么？一架价值1900万美元的挑战者飞机。这架是在法国制造的。”
But then, just as it appears that Morry will have one last chance to ask Dole about his $4 million government pension, the front runner spots Morry, dives straight into his car, and beats Alexander to the airport exit.
但就在莫里似乎有最后一次机会问多尔关于他400万美元政府养老金的问题时，领跑者发现了莫里，直接钻进车里，并在机场出口处抢在了亚历山大前面。
February 10. On to a church in Des Moines to celebrate heterosexual marriages and protest homosexual ones. Together with a crowd of maybe 800 people, Alan Keyes, Phil Gramm, and Pat Buchanan have all turned up to take their whacks. All the rest except Morry have agreed to sign some pledge to make homosexuals as miserable as possible. "Who gives a [BLEEP]?" Morry said when I asked him why he wasn't going. "If you want to be fruity-tooty, so what?"
2月10日。前往得梅因的一座教堂，庆祝异性婚姻并抗议同性婚姻。和大约800人的群众一起，艾伦·凯斯、菲尔·格拉姆和帕特·布坎南都现身来发表他们的看法。除了莫里以外，其他所有人都同意签署某种承诺，尽可能让同性恋者感到痛苦。“谁他妈在乎？”当我问莫里为什么不去时，他说，“如果你想变得轻浮，那又怎样？”
February 12. When I phone Wilfred McCreedy, the winner of Morry's $5,000 drawing, to ask if I could observe the caucus on his farm, I could barely hear his response over the squealing of pigs. Upon my dropping of Morry's name, he said, "That Morry Taylor, he has it exactly right." I was in.
2月12日。当我给莫里5000美元抽奖的赢家威尔弗雷德·麦克里迪打电话，询问我是否可以在他的农场观察党团会议时，我几乎听不清他在猪叫声中的回答。当我提到莫里的名字后，他说：“那个莫里·泰勒，他说得完全正确。”我成功获准。
The McCreedys have been farming the same land in the middle of nowhere for 128 years. They have both traveled some, but it's been 10 years since the McCreedys last had a vacation. And their farm hours make investment banking seem like a walk in the park. Unlike their neighbors, and just about everyone else in Iowa, the McCreedys do not participate in any federal farm programs.
麦克里迪一家在荒无人烟的地方耕种同一块土地已经128年了。他们两人都旅行过一些，但那是麦克里迪一家最后一次休假已经过去10年了。他们的农场工作时间让投资银行看起来就像在公园散步一样轻松。与他们的邻居以及爱荷华州的其他所有人不同，麦克里迪一家不参与任何联邦农业项目。
Before long, the talk drifts to politics. On the phone, McCreedy became a bit worked up about the marriage rally at the church in Des Moines. "Those gays and lesbians are going to protest that meeting?" he said in a tone of utter disbelief. "God damn, that makes me angry." He said he would've driven the two and a half hours to Des Moines to throw his support behind the straights, but his sows were pigging.
没过多久，谈话就转向了政治。在电话里，麦克里迪对得梅因教堂举行的婚姻集会变得有些激动。“那些同性恋者要抗议那个会议？”他以一种完全难以置信的语气说，“该死，这让我很生气。”他说他本会开车两个半小时去得梅因支持异性恋者，但他的母猪正在产仔。
Now, once again, he says how angry the gays made him. But in the flesh, his anger comes across differently. At some level, he may be angry. But his prejudice seems mainly to give him pleasure. As he lays into Clinton, homosexuals, and the US government, his real emotion is more like delight, the delight of a good fan rooting for his team. Go straights!
现在，他再次说同性恋者让他多么生气。但亲眼见到他时，他的愤怒表现得不同。在某种程度上，他可能是生气的。但他的偏见似乎主要给他带来了快乐。当他抨击克林顿、同性恋者和美国政府时，他真正的情绪更像是喜悦，一种好球迷为自己球队加油的喜悦。异性恋者加油！
"Is it true that Forbes owns a Mapplethorpe photograph?" he asks. I say it is. "Dad gum it," he says.
“福布斯拥有一张梅普尔索普的照片是真的吗？”他问。我说是真的。“该死，”他说。
"Oh, Wilfred. What does that matter?" asks Mrs. McCreedy. "That man took pornographic photographs of homosexuals," bellows Mr. McCreedy, at which point Mrs. McCreedy just rolls her eyes. I've tried to make myself as agreeable as possible, but it's only a matter of time before I have to come clean with my left-leaning associations. The tension builds as Mr. McCreedy stakes out a political position on the other end of the spectrum from mine. But it's nearly two hours before I discover that the McCreedys have no idea where I am from or what I do, only that I am a friend of Morry Taylor's.
“哦，威尔弗雷德。那有什么关系？”麦克里迪太太问。“那个男人拍摄了同性恋者的色情照片，”麦克里迪先生大声说道，这时麦克里迪太太只是翻了个白眼。我试图让自己表现得尽可能随和，但这只是时间问题，我迟早得坦白我左倾的背景。随着麦克里迪先生在我政治光谱的另一端设定了一个政治立场，紧张气氛开始加剧。但过了快两个小时，我才发现麦克里迪一家根本不知道我来自哪里，或者我是做什么的，只知道我是莫里·泰勒的朋友。
"You're not from PETA, are you?" asks Mrs. McCreedy, finally. I have no idea what she's talking about. "People for the Ethical Treatment of Animals," she explains. "You just never know when they're going to interrupt. Lately, they've gone to our schools dressed up as carrots to tell the kids not to eat meat."
“你不是来自PETA吧？”麦克里迪太太终于问了。我不知道她在说什么。“善待动物组织，”她解释说，“你永远不知道他们什么时候会来捣乱。最近，他们打扮成胡萝卜去我们的学校告诉孩子们不要吃肉。”
It's truly astonishing. As far as these people knew, I was some protester who had come to disrupt their lives. And yet they still fed me and humored me before venturing to ask. One of the few things I recall from college was that in the Homeric universe, the mark of a civilized persons is his kindness to strangers. The good king feeds Odysseus first, then asks questions later. The cyclops questions him first, then tries to eat him. The McCreedys have the gift of kindness to strangers. I put PETA on the list of things to be against.
这真令人吃惊。据这些人所知，我是一个来打乱他们生活的抗议者。然而，在冒险询问之前，他们仍然给我提供食物并宽容对待我。我从大学里记得的为数不多的事情之一是，在荷马史诗的宇宙中，文明人的标志是对陌生人的善意。善良的国王先喂饱奥德修斯，然后再问问题。独眼巨人先盘问他，然后试图吃掉他。麦克里迪一家有善待陌生人的天赋。我把PETA列入了我要反对的事情清单中。
But now there's no getting around it. I must explain what the hell I'm doing in their kitchen. I mention The New Republic and hold my breath. "Is that Fred Barnes' place?" asks McCreedy. I say that until very recently, it was. "Oh, man," says McCreedy. "I love that guy. Really? Fred Barnes?" It is true. "He's my man," says Mr. McCreedy, slapping me on the shoulder.
但现在无法回避了。我必须解释我在他们厨房里到底在做什么。我提到了《新共和》杂志，并屏住了呼吸。“那是弗雷德·巴恩斯的地方吗？”麦克里迪问。我说直到最近还是。“哦，伙计，”麦克里迪说，“我爱那个家伙。真的？弗雷德·巴恩斯？”这是真的。“他是我的偶像，”麦克里迪先生说着，拍了拍我的肩膀。
It's all very Japanese. Neither of us wants to put a fine point on political disagreement, and so I've been granted the status of conservative by association. After a bit, Mr. McCreedy announces that it's time to "go choring." On the way over in the car, he gives me an idea of what it's like to host a caucus. In the past couple of days, Phil Gramm has called six times, Pat Buchanan twice, and Alan Keyes once. Lamar Alexander has sent McCreedy two books about himself and a videotape. Pollsters call the McCreedys about eight times a day.
这一切都很日本式。我们都不想对政治分歧进行深究，所以我被赋予了关联的保守派身份。过了一会儿，麦克里迪先生宣布是时候“去干杂活”了。在开车去的路上，他让我了解了举办党团会议是什么样的。在过去几天里，菲尔·格拉姆打了六次电话，帕特·布坎南两次，艾伦·凯斯一次。拉马尔·亚历山大寄给麦克里迪两本关于他自己的书和一盘录像带。民意测验员每天给麦克里迪家打大约八次电话。
On the way down the driveway, McCreedy spots a FedEx package poking out from his mail slot. "Maybe it's one of those shirts from Alexander," he says, laughing. It is, or at least it's a collection of Alexandriana. At length, I ask him who he's for. "I'm undecided," he says. "A week ago, I was for Forbes. Then I got my check. I was for Morry Taylor. Now I don't know. You've got to find me one who's going to beat Bill Clinton. Which one do you think?" "None of them," I say.
在下车道的路上，麦克里迪发现一个联邦快递包裹从他的邮箱里露出来。“也许是亚历山大寄来的那些衬衫之一，”他说，大笑着。确实是，或者至少是一堆亚历山大的纪念品。终于，我问他支持谁。“我还未定，”他说，“一周前，我支持福布斯。然后我收到了我的支票。我支持莫里·泰勒。现在我不知道了。你得给我找一个能打败比尔·克林顿的人。你觉得哪一个能行？”“他们都不行，”我说。
"Damn," he says, slapping his hand on the steering wheel. But he's a good sport about it. He's unhappy for about four seconds, and then he's rueful. At length, we arrive at the pig sheds, long, low-slung buildings lined with six-by-five-foot metal troughs filled to the brim with oinkers. McCreedy opens the first door. I recoil and gag. The blast of odor is the most moving thing I've experienced on the campaign trail since I last heard Alan Keyes speak.
“该死，”他说着，拍了拍方向盘。但他对此表现得很有风度。他郁闷了大约四秒钟，然后变得懊悔。终于，我们到达了猪舍，那是一排排低矮的长建筑，里面排满了装满猪崽的六乘五英尺的金属槽。麦克里迪打开第一扇门。我畏缩并干呕起来。这股气味是我在竞选期间听艾伦·凯斯演讲以来经历过的最感人的事情。
While I choke in the corner of his office, McCreedy marches through the pens unfazed. "I don't understand," he hollers out over the noise of the pigs. "When that McLaughlin hollers out 'Fred Beetlebum Barnes', what is that 'Beetlebum' business? What's that about?" I have no idea.
当我在他办公室角落里窒息时，麦克里迪在猪圈里泰然自若地走着。“我不明白，”他在猪的叫声中大声喊道，“当那个麦克劳林大喊‘弗雷德·甲虫屁股·巴恩斯’时，那个‘甲虫屁股’是什么意思？那是怎么回事？”我不知道。
In the first week of each piglet's short life, Wilfred takes a pair of steel clippers and cuts their eye teeth. "I'd like to do that Eleanor Clift," he booms out as I make my way down the row. "Clip her eye teeth. Get Fred Barnes to hold her down."
在每只小猪生命的最初一周，威尔弗雷德拿着一把钢剪刀剪掉它们的尖牙。“我想那样对待埃莉诺·克利夫特，”当我顺着过道走时，他大声说，“剪掉她的尖牙。让弗雷德·巴恩斯把她按住。”
A few hours later, at around 7 o'clock, 25 voters arrive in the McCreedys' living room to discuss the candidates. Only three are even mentioned-- Richard Lugar, Bob Dole, and Alan Keyes. From the sounds of their talk, the people in the room are divided between Keyes and Dole. Just before 8 o'clock, Mr. McCreedy passes around a pad of yellow post-its. Two men then collect the votes in a silver pot and adjourn to the dining room table. There, they quietly add the totals. Dole, 11. Keyes, 7. Alexander, four. Lugar, three.
几小时后，大约7点钟，25名选民来到麦克里迪家的客厅讨论候选人。只有三个人被提到——理查德·卢格、鲍勃·多尔和艾伦·凯斯。从他们的谈话听起来，房间里的人在凯斯和多尔之间产生分歧。快到8点时，麦克里迪先生分发了一个黄色便签纸垫。然后两名男子在一个银锅里收集选票，并退到餐厅桌前。在那里，他们静静地统计总数。多尔，11票。凯斯，7票。亚历山大，4票。卢格，3票。
I ask Mr. McCreedy who he went for, and he laughs and says, "Guess." When the tally is announced to the room, there is a murmur. And then someone shouts, "Wilfred, does that mean you've got to give the $5,000 back?" It's clear they all think that Morry was a fool. He spent $5,000 on the guy, and he couldn't even buy his vote. I prefer to see it another way. Who else but Morry Taylor could give a guy $5,000 and still leave him free to vote for whom he pleases?
我问麦克里迪先生他投给了谁，他大笑着说：“你猜。”当结果在房间里宣布时，有人低声细语。然后有人喊道：“威尔弗雷德，那是不是意味着你得把那5000美元还回去？”很明显，他们都认为莫里是个傻瓜。他在那个人身上花了5000美元，却连他的选票都没买到。我更喜欢换个角度看。除了莫里·泰勒，还有谁能给一个人5000美元，却还能让他自由地投票给任何他喜欢的人？
When Morry Taylor finally dropped out of the presidential race on March 8, Michael Lewis wrote, "We all have a fantasy, and it is profitably exploited by Hollywood, that if only an honest and genuinely free man with a heart of gold ran for president, everything in the world would be put aright." Well, now we know what happens when an honest and genuinely free man with a heart of gold runs for president. He spends $6.5 million and gets 7,000 votes. Michael Lewis' campaign diaries will come out as a book next May from Knopf.
当莫里·泰勒最终在3月8日退出总统竞选时，迈克尔·刘易斯写道：“我们都有一个幻想，并被好莱坞有利可图地利用着，那就是如果只有一位诚实且真正自由、拥有一颗金子般心的男人竞选总统，世界上的所有事情都会被修正。”好吧，现在我们知道当一位诚实且真正自由、拥有一颗金子般心的男人竞选总统时会发生什么了。他花了650万美元，得到了7000张选票。迈克尔·刘易斯的竞选日记将于明年5月由Knopf出版社出版。
Act Three, Another Mixed Legacy. What are we to make of the rich, the successful, the powerful? How should we think about them? Take Ron Brown. Ron Brown is someone who could have had a comfortable, low-stress life. But he is one of those people who threw himself into difficult tasks like, for example, taking over the Democratic Party at one of its lowest moments, uniting it, raising tons of money for it. And when his plane went down, it was a tragedy. But some people have been disturbed at the way many are now eulogizing the former Secretary of Commerce.
第三幕，另一种复杂的遗产。我们该如何看待富人、成功人士和权贵？我们应该如何看待他们？拿罗恩·布朗来说。罗恩·布朗本可以过上舒适、低压力的生活。但他属于那种把自己投身于艰巨任务的人，比如，在民主党最低迷的时刻接管它，团结它，为它筹集巨额资金。当他的飞机失事时，那是一场悲剧。但有些人对许多人现在称颂这位前商务部长的方式感到不安。
Brian Gilmore is a legal services attorney in Washington, DC, a writer, and a poet. And he says that in this moment, when so many people have been praising this successful, powerful man as a kind of post-Martin Luther King saint and role model, his feelings are more complicated.
布莱恩·吉尔摩是华盛顿特区的一名法律服务律师，同时也是一名作家和诗人。他说，在这一刻，当这么多人都在赞美这位成功、强大的男人为一种后马丁·路德·金时代的圣人和榜样时，他的感受更为复杂。
I would be a liar if I said I was a political disciple of Ron Brown. In fact, I cannot ever recall thinking that his particular approach to politics was the answer for the widening woes of black America, or anyone who is deprived in this society, for that matter. It might enable a few privileged, upper-middle-class African-Americans to get richer or gain a foothold into the walls of power and might provide some jobs to a small segment of the population, but I have grave doubts that this approach alone can ever change the fundamental problems the masses of African-Americans face on a daily basis.
如果我说我是罗恩·布朗的政治门徒，那我就是个骗子。事实上，我不记得曾认为他那种特殊的政治方法是解决黑人美国，或这个社会中任何贫困人口所面临的日益严重的苦难的答案。这或许能让少数享有特权的、中上阶层的非裔美国人变得更富有，或在权力的围墙内获得立足点，也可能为一小部分人口提供一些工作机会，但我非常怀疑仅凭这种方法是否能改变广大非裔美国人每天面临的基本问题。
But despite this glaring difference in our political ideals, I was deeply saddened by the death of the man who I admired greatly and who was clearly a role model for me. In his own way, on his own terms, he seemed to solve the W.E.B. DuBois dilemma of double consciousness that we African-Americans are born with and face our every waking moment in this country. He was a man who mastered the art of floating carefully between black America and white America. His way of accomplishing this most difficult task was to get inside the huddle and become a player in American politics and society.
但尽管我们在政治理想上存在这种明显的差异，我还是对他这样一位我非常钦佩、并且显然是我的榜样的男人的去世感到深切的悲痛。他以自己的方式，按自己的条件，似乎解决了我们非裔美国人与生俱来的、在这个国家每时每刻都要面对的W.E.B.杜波依斯的双重意识困境。他是一个掌握了在黑人美国和白人美国之间小心翼翼游走艺术的男人。他完成这项最艰巨任务的方法是进入核心圈子，成为美国政治和社会中的一名参与者。
Though my life is seemingly taking a vastly different path than his, I have to admit that in a lot of ways, Brown and I are very similar. Both of us were born in Washington, DC, attended private schools where middle-class kids were urged to succeed. And like him, I, too, have become a lawyer. But that is where many of our similarities end. Ron Brown was a partner in a law firm that represented some of the richest clients in the world. I have been an attorney for the past three years representing some of Washington's poorest and most destitute residents.
尽管我的人生轨迹看起来与他截然不同，但我不得不承认，在很多方面，我和布朗非常相似。我们都出生于华盛顿特区，就读于那些鼓励中产阶级孩子追求成功的私立学校。像他一样，我也成了一名律师。但我们的相似之处也就仅此而已。罗恩·布朗曾是一家律师事务所的合伙人，该事务所代表着世界上一些最富有的人。而过去三年来，我一直是一名律师，代表着华盛顿最贫穷和最落魄的居民。
Brown came along at that brief, magical time in American history when the civil rights movement had reshaped the country and opportunities for educated African-Americans seemed to be unlimited. He worked for a traditional civil rights organization, the Washington Urban League, and eventually became part of Edward Kennedy's congressional staff. Like so many other minority professionals at that time, he honestly believed in America and its opportunities following the '60s.
布朗出现在美国历史上那段短暂而神奇的时期，当时民权运动已经重塑了这个国家，受过良好教育的非裔美国人似乎拥有无限的机会。他曾为一个传统的民权组织——华盛顿城市联盟工作，最终成为了爱德华·肯尼迪国会办公室的一员。和当时许多其他少数族裔专业人士一样，他在60年代之后真诚地相信美国及其机遇。
By contrast, when I came along in search of my position in the world, Ronald Reagan had become president, and the civil rights movement was over. My friends and I were convinced he was going to cut all educational funding for African-Americans and make us join the Army. I can never forget hearing, while I was in college, of the Reagan administration's open assault on educational grants and social programs that would ultimately change the face of the country.
相比之下，当我开始寻求自己在社会中的位置时，罗纳德·里根已经当选总统，民权运动也已结束。我和我的朋友们确信他会削减所有针对非裔美国人的教育经费，并强迫我们参军。我永远无法忘记，当我在大学时，听到里根政府公开抨击教育补助金和社会项目，而这些举措最终改变了这个国家的面貌。
To me, Ron Brown represented a certain type of African-American politician, the kind that emerged from the riots of the '60s, with so much promise in the '70s, only to watch black communities nationwide crumble and self-destruct in the '80s under Reagan.
对我来说，罗恩·布朗代表了某种特定类型的非裔美国政客，他们从60年代的骚乱中崛起，在70年代充满希望，却在80年代里根执政期间，眼睁睁看着全国的黑人社区分崩离析、自毁灭亡。
This is the world of my clients. A public housing tenant that I represented had her apartment taken over by drug dealers. The city refused to help her get the dealers out, but they did try to evict her. Another tenant's ceiling caves in and injures her daughter after she had complained for months about a leaky ceiling, and the city doesn't respond. The city sued her too.
这就是我客户所处的世界。我代理的一位公共住房租户的公寓被毒贩占领了。市政府拒绝帮她赶走毒贩，却试图驱逐她。另一位租户在投诉漏水天花板数月无果后，天花板塌落砸伤了她的女儿，而市政府对此毫无回应。市政府还起诉了她。
One wonders why we have scenes like these all over Afro-America with so many African-Americans now inside the huddle just like Ron Brown was. Seeing the headlines about his plane crash, I'm struck now by how black America has deteriorated to the greatest extent economically, spiritually, and socially, precisely in the years since so many black Americans gained access to the club.
人们不禁要问，为什么我们在整个非裔美国人的社区里随处可见这样的景象，而像罗恩·布朗那样进入核心圈层的非裔美国人却如此之多。看到关于他坠机的头条新闻，我深受触动，黑人美国在经济、精神和社会层面竟然恶化到了如此地步，而这恰恰发生于那么多黑人美国人获得进入精英圈层的机会之后。
Brian Gilmore is a legal services attorney and author of Elvis Presley is Alive and Well and Living in Harlem .
布莱恩·吉尔摩是一位法律援助律师，也是《猫王还活着，在哈莱姆生活得很好》一书的作者。
Our program was produced by Nancy Updike and myself today, with Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, and Dolores Wilber, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt and Margy Rochlin. Musical help from Rumpty Rattles and the Blues Before Sunrise Radio Network with Steve Cushing. Some music today in our Michael Lewis story was composed for our program by Chicago composer Eric Leonardson.
今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我共同制作，彼得·克劳尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和多洛雷斯·威尔伯参与制作，保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林担任特约编辑。音乐支持来自Rumpty Rattles乐队和史蒂夫·库兴主持的“日出前的布鲁斯”广播网。今天迈克尔·刘易斯故事中的部分配乐由芝加哥作曲家埃里克·伦纳德森为本节目创作。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
【资助方信息】
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. See you next week with more true stories of This American Life .
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，届时将有更多来自《美国生活》的真实故事。